hmm I want to sleep just like this I
wanna make a model okay let's do it
I always start with a base so cute oh my
god really obsessed with polygons so
this one I've done a hexagon that's
pretty dope as he's drawing I slowly
start adding on ideas and make his brain
explode and he pulls thing from all the
windows had on it like that oh my gosh
please don't say that
part of my brain thinks it would be like
six times as much work that's what it
would look like but the other part of my
brain is like man it would look so epic
it's so cool let's try yeah
once the original drawings get made I
have a conversation with my dad and I
show him the picture and then he goes
ultra nerd on me because he's an
engineer and then he'll come at me and
he'll be like an imaginary number has in
it the square root of minus 1 there is
no such thing when you multiply it by
itself that you will get minus 1 he was
also an architect so he's been a huge
inspiration in my life so it's a way for
him to like do stuff that he's always
loved but also with me sometimes he
tries to like take the design in a
direction I don't want to go you know he
was like what about a Pentagon I was
like nah bro I say bro to my dad
sometimes I gotta let him know what's up
so the next thing I want to make a model
of the cabin just using little sticks
that I cut on the table saw I like that
because you can really get a sense of
how big things need to be if you do it
to scale oh my gosh look he's a gun
slinger over here there's a little
person gonna be able to walk inside and
go up the little ladder and sleep in the
loft and how much space is it gonna be
and you can actually move the bottle
around to be like where do you want it
to orient where do you want the awning
to be what should that look like well we
already made a model we shipped it key
[Music]
so now we're having to remake it so we
can take it through the woods and kind
of pick a spot for it so never use the
shipping company I never said it okay
now that we built the model we're gonna
go walk around our property and pick out
a good spot for it right here no
absolutely look how beautiful it is
look at that dude look at that Sun
coming through here I'm gonna be tempted
for this I think of the light is so
pretty right now I know what I'm looking
for something that's gonna look super
picturesque when you're looking at it
and then also when you're walking out
the door what are you gonna see what do
you think about right there look at that
Moss thing you know I know right that's
what I'm thinking here like this oh this
is pretty shot this way this is a leaner
this actually it was it's kind of goes
with the shape of the cavity so this has
to come out no it has to come out we
can't keep we're going to have to cut
down maybe we'll find a spot where we
don't have to cut down a tree this is
just the first one
[Music]
whoo I love that imagine walking out of
the door right here
your has to have a look this trick No
yeah this would be cool I don't love it
this way and I mean I think this is a
gorgeous thing to look out over that's
why it's awesome we definitely have to
take out these two trees but this reason
why not right here
there's not glad enough this commute I
like it I can so see it but I also was
kind of digging right over here too I
love this spot you love this spot do you
not look at this boss this might be a
sign I see one two seven different kinds
of moss right hearing this one yeah this
might be ours
so does this mean we can break ground
tomorrow yeah we could break ground
tomorrow where you're gonna live little
cabin
I love it
[Music]
please be sure to LIKE and subscribe
this channel so you never miss an update
and please back us on patreon so we can
keep these free videos coming yes free
ain't free we need you back us please